Speaker 1: Today, I'm going to have one
of my favorite voicemails ever for you.
This is unreal. I've never had anything
like this. I believe this may be the best
series of voicemails we've received. A woman
thought that I said something and called in and
absolutely crushed me for it. Hangs Up, realizes
she called the wrong show and then calls back to
apologize. You have to hear this. Listen to this.
Speaker 6: Can we tell you to go and get your ass
out of women's business? You're an idiot.
And people like you are going to get
strung up and hung over watching
you watch as son of a bitch
because all this is going to put up an asshole
like you. Oh God, I despise you. You're a punk.
You're going to be somebody punk in prison.
Speaker 1: So I heard that and I thought,
What on earth is she talk? I don't even
know vaguely what she's talking about.
And then I got this voicemail two minutes later.
Speaker 6: Hey, kiddo, I think I left you the
wrong message. You're the gentleman on the
free speech station. I like you very much,
my dear. Thank you. But the person that was
quoted and saying that stuff about women
and trying to act like they didn't know the
judge's name capacity, brown Jackson's name,
it was insulting, and I wanted that message to go
to that guy, not to use me. So the message you say
that you don't get hung for that because I am mad
at these men trying to put their noses in women's
business, right? It's none of their business,
you know? So sorry about that. I thought that
that caption there was from that person is from.
Speaker 1: Yes. Apology accepted. The best
series of calls I have ever received
on this show. On today's bonus show,
we will talk about the passing of former
Secretary of State Madeleine Albright.
We will talk about the fact that we don't
know what's going on with Supreme Court
Justice Clarence Thomas, who's been missing
from the court for four days now. We don't
know if he's still in the hospital, we don't
know what's going on. And we will talk about
Trump's understatement of Republican Mo Brooks.
All of those stories on today's bonus, Joe.
Sign up at join Packman dot com
Unidentified: and we will see you back.